♪ ♪
>> Sean: HERE WITH THE
REACTION ON ALL OF THE BREAKING
NEWS TONIGHT, TRUMP ORGANIZATION
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT ERIC
TRUMP.
CAN I REDO SOMETHING?
GREAT TO SEE YOU, BY THE WAY,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT, NUMBER TWO'S ON
THE WAY, AND WHAT DO WE KNOW?
>> WE ARE EXCITED, .
>> Sean: I DON'T REVEAL
SOURCES LIKE OTHER PEOPLE.
>> I KNOW.
>> Sean: DO YOU KNOW WE HAVE
FINANCIAL OPTIMISM, 18 YEAR
HIGH?
56% OF AMERICANS, THEIR CURRENT
FINANCIAL SITUATION THE HIGHEST
SINCE 2001, 69% SAID THEY EXPECT
TO BE BETTER OFF FINANCIALLY IN
A YEAR, THE HIGHEST IN 16 YEARS.
EUROPE IS AT 0.3% GROWTH THE
LAST TWO QUARTERS, AND EVEN
DURING A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN,
YOUR DAD GOT US 3.2%, OBAMA
COULDN'T GET THAT IN A YEAR IN
HIS ENTIRE PRESIDENCY.
>> AND HIGHEST STOCK MARKET OF
ALL TIME, AND THE BEST CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE OF ALL TIME, LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT OF ALL TIME.
LOWEST JOBLESSNESS CLAIMS OF ALL
TIME.
I CAN GO ON AND ON AND ON.
WE HAVE THE HOTTEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD, NO QUESTION ABOUT IT
THAT MY FATHER IS DOING EVERY
THING HE SAID HE WOULD DO, WHICH
IS PUT JET FUEL ON THIS ECONOMY,
AND HE HAS DONE IT.
WE ARE THE ENVY OF THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
YOU LOOK AT THE CHARADE HE HAS
SEEN OVER THE DAYS, IT IS SAD
BECAUSE WE ARE DOING SO, AND THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO DISTRACT FROM
THAT, EVERYTHING HE SAID
HE WOULD ACHIEVE FOR THIS
COUNTRY COME ALL THEY WANT TO DO
IS DISTRACT EVERYBODY ELSE FROM
THAT.
IT IS ACTUALLY HUGELY
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, ERIC, WHEN
YOU HAVE TIME, YOU HAVE A YOUNG
SON WHO IS A GREAT KID, WHEN
YOUR TIME, I KNOW YOU WATCH THE
SHOW.
YOU KNOW THE ISSUES WE HAVE BEEN
COVERING THAT HAVE BEEN
SEPARATE, APART, AND UNIQUE FROM
THE REST OF THE MEDIA PAIR THERE
ARE A FEW OF US, LAURA, TUCKER,,
AND MANY OTHERS, RUSH
AND MARK HAVE BEEN GREAT ON THE
RADIO.
IT IS OVER.
IT IS FINISHED.
ANYTHING FROM HERE ON IN HIS
NOISE.
>> THEY WON'T LET IT GO.
>> Sean: EVERYTHING ELSE, NOW
IT IS JUST REALLY BEGINNING.
IT REALLY IS.
IT'S INTERMISSION, AND IS NOW
THE SECOND HALF AGAIN.
>> YOU KNOW, SEAN, THEY WON'T
LET IT GO.
THEY WERE SO WRONG AT THE
ELECTION.
HE COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA, THAT
GOT DEBUNKED.
WELL, THERE IS OBSTRUCTION, THAT
LET'S SUBPOENA EVERYBODY IN THE
TRUNK ORBIT, LET'S SUBPOENA HIS
FAMILY, LET'S SUBPOENA HIS
LAWYERS, HIS BANKS, HIS
ACCOUNTANTS.
LET'S JUST THROW A NET OUT INTO
THE MIDDLE OF THE RIVER AND HOPE
WE CATCH SOMETHING, BECAUSE THE
NARRATIVE ONCE AGAIN TOTALLY
FAILED, AND TRUMP WAS RIGHT, HE
WAS WIRETAPPED AT THE VERY
BEGINNING, HE WAS SPIED ON, AND
THE DEEP STATE DOES EXIST.
EVERYTHING YOU SAY EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT WAS ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
NOW THEY ARE GRASPING AT STRAWS,
TRYING AGAIN.
THIS IS WHAT YOU GET OUT OF
THESE PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO WORK FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY DON'T WANT
TO DO THEIR JOBS IN CONGRESS.
I SAY THIS AS A CIVILIAN, PEOPLE
ARE SICK AND TIRED OF THIS
NONSENSE.
THEY WANT THEIR LEGISLATORS TO
ACTUALLY WORK AND DO THEIR JOBS.
THAT IS WHY YOU SEE THE APPROVAL
RATING OF CONGRESS IS TERRIBLE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE INCOMPETENT.
>> Sean: WE SOUGHT ON ELECTION
NIGHT, I REMEMBER, I CALLED YOUR
DAD AND SAID SOMEBODY IS DRAWING
STRAWS RIGHT NOW, GOING TO BRING
A REALLY BAD NEWS, BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THE EXIT POLLS PRETTY
EARLY.
BUT NOW THEY WANT A FISHING
EXPEDITION, LET'S GET THE TAX
RECORDS, LET'S EMPOWER THE IRS
TO BLUDGEON A POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
LET'S GO FISHING AND GET HIS
BANK RECORDS.
IF YOUR FATHER CURED CANCER AND
GAVE EVERY AMERICAN $5 MILLION
AND                $5 MILLION,
I'M STILL CONVINCED THEY WOULD
BE OBSESSED WITH BREACHING THIS
PSYCHOTIC HATRED TOWARD HAMPERED
>> BUT SEAN, IT TELLS YOU THEY
ARE FAILING AS A PARTY, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY LEADERS OUT
THERE.
THESE CANDIDATES ALL LOOK VERY
WEAK TO ME, I WELCOME RUNNING
AGAINST QUITE FRANKLY ANY OF
THEM, HELPING MY FATHER IN EVERY
WAY WE CAN.
THEY ARE FAILING, SEAN.
THEY DON'T HAVE A MESSAGE, THEY
DON'T HAVE PROPER LEADERSHIP,
AND I AM TELLING YOU, HE'S GOING
TO WIN THIS THING AGAIN IN 2020
BECAUSE THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
DERANGED.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, WE ARE
ENERGY INDEPENDENT FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 75 YEARS.
BY THE WAY, YOU WANT TO BEAT THE
HOSTILE REGIME OF RUSSIA?
YOU WANT TO BRING PUTIN TO HIS
KNEES?
KEEP PRODUCING ENERGY.
IT IS OVER FOR THEM.
>> HE IS DOING THAT BETTER THAN
ANY PERSON IN THE WORLD.
>> Sean: CONGRATS ON THE GREAT